[Music]
nick
remember how i had to take that uber
yesterday to get to work because my car
wouldn't start
i almost didn't make it to work today i
almost had to take another uber
so this is the boosted board it's an
amazing piece of equipment you may
recognize it from mario skate that we
shot a couple years ago
what if i actually rode this to work
instead of driving this car my issue is
that this booster board tops out at
about 5 miles of range whereas i live
about 15 miles away i've actually seen
videos of people who have modified their
boosted boards by putting extra battery
packs on them you want to consider the
right battery to use and the first
obvious choice is a lithium polymer
battery known as a lipo these are
commonly used in like drones and rc cars
and stuff like that today but what
piqued my interest
is this 18650 battery made by panasonic
what makes this thing special is that
this is the exact battery used today
it's powered the world's most
technologically advanced cars on the
market yeah what's the name of your car
joffrey joffrey the one true king
so yeah the p85d which has exactly 7100
batteries inside
and the way it's arranged is that you
have basically 16
modules of like 444 batteries
man that does not get old that's
incredible the batteries in this car are
designed to hold a lot of energy but not
output that energy very fast all right
so imagine that this glass of water
represents the boosted board battery
which is a
lithium iron phosphate battery and that
this
bottle of water represents the panasonic
batteries found inside tesla cars which
is the
lithium nickel cobalt aluminum dioxide
battery
with the water inside both representing
electrical energy
this one for instance can pour all the
water out really really fast
oh but look now this glass of water is
empty no more water
this one even though it holds a lot more
water it takes a lot longer to pour it
all out
because it can't pour it out that fast
you got this bottleneck here
if i wanted to make this pour out water
faster how do i do that well the answer
is to add
another bottle of water in parallel so
what happens is that with both of these
pouring at the same time
you have double the output rate of water
so much water now
why use a smaller amount of water when
you can have a lot of water and output
just as fast
if these batteries can actually power
this massive car to go
so fast surely having a couple packs in
parallel on my boosted board
will be able to deliver the power i need
in the longevity that i also need to get
to work
you're gonna ride all the way to work
yeah dude it's like 15 miles away oh man
yeah hopefully it works my plan is to
make a battery pack that matches the
voltage of the booster board itself
which is about 40 volts
i have to take each of these 10 connect
them end to end and then take the second
10 and also connect those end to end
this will give me two packs of 10
batteries each that'll connect in
parallel to double the output rate and
the capacity
we have the battery pack right here and
we have the control board this is where
all the circuitry goes
and if i lift this off we'll see exactly
what i'm talking about so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to splice the
batteries directly into
the cables where they meet at the
control board okay i have to
solder wires directly to the board i
could destroy
this 1500 piece of equipment and i don't
think warranty will cover this
what i'm doing here is making custom
bullet connectors so that i can connect
the batteries
directly to the boosted board itself
[Music]
i've made two bullet connectors on wire
this plate actually covers the control
board and i'm going to drill a hole
straight through this so that i can take
these connectors which connect to the
battery and will stick out of it
and then i'll get the right length and
then i'll snip these here and solder the
ends of these onto the control board
that'll do wonderfully
and be able to pull this up and over oh
man look at that
here are the two wires we're most
concerned with i'm actually going to
cut a small little hole to expose this
wire
and expose this wire from there i'll be
able to take these and solder them
directly to the cable
this is actually the part i'm most
nervous about simply because i'm
officially avoiding the warranty now
uh hopefully this thing doesn't break i
think it worked man these things are
stuck
on there they are not coming off there's
now exposed connectors here so i'm going
to cover that up with liquid tape which
is essentially just electrical tape but
fluid
the last step of this mod is to create
these little y connectors little
splitters here
that will connect the batteries together
and into the boosted board as a single
stream of power
up we have an issue that i probably
should have checked on first
i let the boosted board get too low on
energy and then i just let it sit there
for
months over time batteries kind of lose
their charge and now
the battery charge has gotten too low in
the boosted board to even turn on
and if i plug it in green light comes on
red charging
now it's blinking and there is a way to
fix this dead battery problem
we need to borrow your car by towing
myself behind nick's car
i turned the motors into power
generators which add enough energy
into the battery to revive it and allow
it to be charged again
yes i turn on
[Music]
the board has been charging for the last
half hour now the moment of truth is to
see
if it turns on hey okay it's green
solid green that means it's on does it
connect
[Applause]
yes it works just
do it
oh i headed now we fixed it nick dude
i got this incredibly strong velcro if i
just pop this on
we got this guy these two batteries are
connected together and
into the boosted board we're good seems
to be working
[Music]
how can you tell the ranch that is a bit
of an issue there is no way to tell the
range the only way to know is to test it
i'm excited so for all intents and
purposes this is where i'm starting very
close to griffith park
here in burbank slash glendale area
and i'm gonna be going down along this
bike path right next to the la river
[Music]
i'm out driving right alongside i-5 here
and look at traffic i'm going the same
speed
kind of i'm approximately two or three
miles away from where i started
normally i'd be halfway through a blue
support battery even though it says that
i'm basically dead
so far that is the scariest part about
this mod is that i have no way of
actively monitoring what my battery
levels are so that's a bit scary
this is it if i take one more step i'll
be the farthest away from home
i've ever been come on sam
remember what bildo used to say a good
half of this entire ride is right along
this river so i'm just gonna keep riding
along this river as far as i can go
well that sucks
should i just say screw it and go past
it there's work over there they might
stop me
i think i'm pretty fast i might be able
to
get around them just continue on
i don't think i'm okay what an annoyance
so this fine gentleman basically just
told me i can't continue this
way because of all the flooding there's
all this stuff that you got to chop down
is that right
he's got a gopro on me too so
unfortunately i have to turn around and
go back
i don't know how far how far do you
think that is half a mile so what if i
just
decided to ignore you and just keep
going that's all the ponies right
yeah i figured as much have a good day
that's unfortunate hopefully that
doesn't add too much more time to my
travel this is a big detour
i don't know how much extra distance
this is going to add to my trip
but that being said now i have to figure
out my way to work on the la streets
okay
here i am about nine miles into the ride
and i'm walking up a hill because the
boosted board can't handle my weight
on such a simple hill it has enough
charge to continue going for miles but i
guess i can't quite have the torque i
needed
which is what i was hoping for i just
need more batteries in parallel to
properly do this
but here's what i don't get i'm actually
getting pretty good readings from the
multimeter
35.6 and then 36 even for the right
battery pack
which means that all the battery packs
are at the same voltage and i still have
a fair amount of charge left in them
so why am i not getting the current draw
that i want
i still got another several miles to go
so hopefully i'll be able to make it
all right i'm about
three and a half miles away from the
studio now but this is
killing me i've been going on average
like five miles an hour
look at this
so close to making it to the studio i'm
less than two miles away
and i'm actually potentially causing
damage by continuing to ride but
i'm gonna keep going
all right it's official i am on hunter
street this last leg of the journey
14 miles didn't quite make it but it's
still going
i made it we made it
you're late man dude okay so i left it
like 9 30. i know it's like
one now in my defense i did have to like
fly the drone and check the battery
basically the second half of the ride i
couldn't go faster like five miles an
hour in the last two miles i was having
like be a regular old skateboarder
this means i can't i can't depend on
this to get to work remember that water
analogy these two represent the battery
packs i made and this represents the
boosted board battery the way batteries
work is that they start at a certain
voltage and then they drop
voltages until they reach a point where
they can't drop any further for the
boosted board battery that's about 33
and a half volts
so once the battery gets to that voltage
it no longer works
unfortunately the two battery packs i
made can continue to work down to 30
volts
as soon as we reach the bottom of this
battery we can't utilize any more power
from these batteries so i have all this
energy
that i can't utilize yet so i need your
help i need to somehow make it so that i
can utilize all of the energy
in a smaller voltage range is that even
possible i don't know if that's possible
what if i used some sort of like boost
converter to up the battery voltage
over the course of time let's brainstorm
together maybe we can figure out a way
to make this battery system
work thanks for watching in the meantime
i'm gonna be reading all the comments
and trying to devise a better way to do
this booster board
or i might just figure out a way to do
this with one wheel
is that even possible
[Music]
hello